psychonauts 2.
here is the mental health advisory um i
just thought i would leave it on this
bit so i could read it to you all just
so that you all know
what we're about to get into here it's a
great game but it does touch on some
very serious topics and i'd like you to
be aware of that so mental health
advisory psychonauts 2 contains artistic
interpretations of serious mental con
mental conditions including addiction
ptsd panic attacks anxiety and delusions
there are also images that may be
upsetting to people with dental phobia
the
dental phobia these conditions are
usually presented in a light-hearted or
even comical manner so therefore like
kid-friendly like i said but might still
be distressing to some players
ultimately psychonauts 2 is a game about
empathy and healing if you find yourself
experiencing a negative reaction to this
content or if you need mental health
resources please visit take this dot org
mental health resources i think this is
really nice for them to have at the
start of the game
um because like i just said for anyone
who's just come in i really enjoyed
psychonauts one i thought they touched
on some really deep topics in a very fun
light-hearted way for children or young
people to digest and it really games
like this really do stick with you or
stuck with me at least it makes an
impact and i i always really like when
games try to touch on
very serious topics
i think games are a perfect format to do
it because it's a safe environment to
explore these things
party time
uh yeah safe environment to explore
these things and also have fun with it
so
video games the best
let's get into this dear true psychic
tales magazine it's me again rasputin
aguado i know i write a lot and you
haven't printed any of my true psychic
submissions so far but this one's
different this one's true
i just helped rescue truman sonato the
grand head of the psychonauts and father
of lily zenato
my girlfriend although the term is still
very fresh and might need fact checking
before we go to print there was a kiss
but
okay i'm already getting off track let
me start at the beginning i grew up in
the circus the aquato family circus a
ragtag little caravan of acrobats run by
my parents we were taught all our lives
to hate and fear psychics or fortune
tellers as we knew them all because of
some old thing where they cursed the
aquatos to die in water problem is
i am psychic i have been all my life i
hid my powers from my family practicing
them in secret
until one fateful night after a show a
mysterious stranger handed me a brochure
for whispering rock psychic summer camp
a training facility for psychic kids
operated by the international espionage
agency we all know as
thanks
psychonauts
i ran away from home that night when i
got to whispering rock i blended in
seamlessly with the other campers
superstar secret agent sasha 9 and mia
vodello
levitation
i learned pyro and telekinesis from ford
crawler himself he was all over camp
literally all over due to his ability to
teleport he even took up psychic
residence in my head
which i could prove to you if you had a
piece of bacon needless to say things
were going great the one little catch
was that the head coach of the camp was
stealing campers brains and putting them
inside armored death tanks that i guess
he was gonna use to take over the world
or something i went into his mind and
found out he just had some issues with
his father i mean who does it right now
he's okay
not great but
okay
just as fort cruller was making me an
honorary psychonaut for all my hard work
word came in the truman zonato had been
kidnapped
so my fellow psychonauts and i jumped in
a jet and set out to find them our
search led us to an abandoned underwater
outpost of the psychonauts in a
dangerous part of the ocean known
as the rhombus of ruin
we found truman there held captive by dr
lobato unlicensed dentist and amateur
brain surgeon we freed grand head sonato
but he's got silarian poisoning and
can't tell us what happened we know
lobato wasn't acting alone but he won't
tell us who hired him to kidnap truman
agent nine has an idea how to get the
information using an elaborate psychic
construction implanted in lubato's mind
it's risky but
that's just a way of life when you're a
psychonaut if i don't make it back i
really hope you consider publishing my
letter and also please consider the
sample layout and illustrations i
included well
i better get my head in the right place
that was a lot of information it's about
to begin
it looks so good
i love how they kept the same style but
they've just made it look better more
crisp i love it
ah do i want to play with the controller
or
i don't know
let's try controller
i'm gonna look at the music as well this
is gonna be good let me know um how
audio is uh if game's too loud if i'm
too
quiet like or too loud let me know
hey rick's alive
uh
anna banan just wanted to stop by and
say thanks for making your video on girl
gamers advice on what can you see i was
hesitant to enter the industry after
graduation but that video gave me the
push i needed to keep going yes
i'm so happy to hear that oh thank you
so much that's yeah that's made my
evening
that's why i made that video i'm really
happy um if you have any questions feel
free to like reach out to me on twitter
instagram anything um
yeah i'll try and get back to you
but
i'm so happy to hear that
best of luck to you
okay new game
[Music]
three days ago truman zanato the grand
head of the psychonauts
was kidnapped
yesterday with my help the psychonauts
rescued truman from the underwater lair
of dr lobato but trust me
there's no way lobato is working alone
today
we're on a mission
find out who hired dr lobato to kidnap
truman zanato
my name
is
is my first official day on the job
[Music]
oh no he looks so boring what happened
this is what happens when you become
adult
[Music]
everything okay in here raz
oh
hey lily
yeah i don't know it's just
i've dreamed about working at
psychonauts headquarters all my life
i just thought it would be more
you know
come on we're going to be late for the
morale corral
[Music]
like he already looks like he's a 30
year old man and that's how we managed
to raise profits
uh
the 900
this quarter
[Applause]
that's right
thank you
and that brings us to our next topic
uh sasha still have the talking turtle
[Music]
maury
sorry i just like the clapping
it's now time to give out the award for
employee of the year
the prize for this year's award is an
all-expenses-paid tropical vacation
hope it's me
the winner of this award may be one of
our newest members but he's also one of
our most improved
congratulations to
cali gusto loboto
way to go cow you're gonna love this
vacation package
i'm jealous
i
i've never won anything open on a
vacation
i don't have to go on a boat do i
no darling
[Music]
all you need to do is get this vacation
request approved by your supervisor
just a formality you just need to get
this form signed by your boss
my boss yes darling or you could just
tell us who your boss is and we could
maybe he doesn't want this tropical
vacation after all
look back i want it i'm employee of the
year yes you are darling now off you go
get that form signed by your boss the
person who hired you
the person you work for
okay
[Music]
hurry up or i take that vacation myself
rasputin
i'm on him i love that little swirl
party keep up with him rise and he'll
lead you straight to his boss
[Music]
oh i can't even jump what he's kidding
me
fellow colleagues do you know where the
boss's office is my boss is tough but
fair well good for you i guess
[Music]
oh it's nice of him to wait down there
for us
why am i talking about
i need to follow lubato i am fairly
compensated for my work really so am i
so how long have you worked here i have
worked here from one to three years hmm
mondays am i right sorry can't talk it's
no meetings monday
[Music]
you guys stay here i'm on it i am a
typical psychonauts employee huh
okay you gonna help her time for the
morale corral right
unless you can't do anything i can't run
away we'll try to hit him off be careful
darling
okay
stay close to him
don't freak him out
i am acting casual what's that i said i
love casual friday am i right
monday attention
[Music]
okay
i think he suspects something he's
taking counter measures just remember
your basic ratings are right
are you
following me yeah i'm just slapping
boxes
you are following me this was all a
trick i'm not employee of the year
[Music]
i'm the greatest dentist of our century
[Music]
all agents the tooth has gone bad repeat
the tooth has gone bad
we are in position to intercept roger
[Music]
okay
just go
looking for me
well come and get me
why are you taking home
long
[Laughter]
i don't think you understand the
gravity of the situation you're in
watch out
hey you're not supposed to walk that way
wow
come on
[Music]
coach no time for small talk soldier the
enemy is on the move but we've got him
cornered this way quick
hurry we can't let them shake us
now before the procedure it's very very
important that we clean out your
dentists
[Music]
i can't lift that tooth there's a door
up there we just need to make some sort
of ladder stairs out of here
finally
lots of figments of lubato's imagination
in here
differently imagination littered all
over your mental words your rank will
increase for every 100 when you see a
figment suck it up soldiers
[Music]
[Music]
i love how they've kept it any ideas
very similar to the person that just
kind of upgraded it let me upload
there's a little one
coach
there were no teeth in sasha's plan
that's what i told him but he's all no
weapons maury
oh that's why the tooth got wrenched
[Music]
great job following orders private you
go on ahead i'll take up the rear guard
i thought the big tooth was upsetting
well
it's soldier through private unzipped
that dental door
good job soldier
what's that light oh
zip it back up again slip it
yeah
now that your cap is clean
let's check out those choppers
hmm
if i didn't know better i'd swear this
place had gremlins
no problem i'm sure i can do this in the
dark
uh
coach
this room is definitely not in sasha's
plan
in fact i think it's a trap
that's just a sensor
everybody has those
live in your mind and stamp out things
that don't
belong like us
you'll handle this one i'll find a way
out
don't be taken
it's okay i slap him
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you just have to do your thing with the
dental door here oh
yeah
i
can't even look at it
[Music]
[Music]
give me
didn't i need it
oh
so i remember this i need to get like
fat uh
it's a duffel bag
uh oh a tag a tag
and it's it's like hidden memories
uh it's baggage you know how everyone
has baggage
here we go yes got the duffel bag tag
[Music]
[Music]
oh i thought i was gonna get to see what
the baggage was
maybe not
[Music]
[Music]
memory vault maybe that's where i get to
sleep some minds try to protect
themselves by knocking memories away in
bolts
chase them down and bust them open to
reveal the depressed memories
that's one of dr lobato's vaults
passport map money
outpost charlie psycho
delta did he find like a secret
hideaway den thing that's a turtle
a secret laboratory
he's turning
people into fish
fishes
enhancement under the sea
dental tails okay i should try to catch
it could be high value intel inside
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
looking good
[Music]
oh
yep
[Music]
hey see what you can find that way see
you on the other side
[Music]
looks like some sort of conference room
in here was hilton is that you
i need oh i'm coming sasha
[Music]
brush mutant careful it's a poof ha
here's the hat box tag
[Music]
someone is helping him he couldn't
couldn't do this himself
please
that is not providing any response
that is not providing any new scientific
insight
rasputin
thank you
please let's get clear of this
aggressive uvula
sasha
how is lobato breaking through the
office construct he couldn't be doing
this on his own he must be getting help
from someone even more
sinister
get ready rasputin
way out of here quickly
yeah don't bother with them little mooks
you want to go for the gold you gotta
grab the big boys
help me carry this one will you frankie
are they helping why are they helping us
i can't believe they got me too frankie
the moocs
[Music]
oh by the way i'm sorry i'm not
uh
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
did you even brush before you came in
here today
honestly it's a mess in there
here rinse and spit
oh no not back in the trap trap
coach
coach where'd he go
oh well that's a good sign what is it
that is a regret if lubato has regrets
then maybe there's a way we can still
get to him let's get out of here and
find lobato
sasha
our regret's dangerous oh yes extremely
take care of that one will you while i
find an exit
making him do all of the work
[Music]
oh
[Music]
good job rasputin
unfortunately i can't find a way out of
here anywhere uh sasha how long is that
golden door been there golden what did
somebody say go
frankie here's a chance for revenge ah
not these guys i'll keep looking
watch out again
i'm coming to see you ma
rasputin you see what you can find
through that door i'm going to stay here
and attempt to repair my construct this
i'm good at making weird characters
tooth fairy geezers who would have
thought of that
okay have we found we found everything
in here right we have a tag though so
there's gonna be another
briefcase or whatever you would call it
around
[Music]
[Music]
oh this is not getting any better is
that you
come down here lily i'm coming
[Music]
slippery hurry up
here i come
[Music]
still got that water phobia huh it's not
a phobia it's a curse
back in grulovia my whole family was
cursed to die in water and yeah yeah
super sad look at these posters
i think someone else planted these in
the bottle's mind
and make sure he didn't tell us who
hired him to kidnap your dad let's get
rid of that maybe it will help
help me burn these posters right
shut it nice
things on fire
um
[Music]
forever
oh looks like you found an even bigger
room i'm gonna catch up to lovato okay
i'll catch up after i make sure
we're not here to hurt you we just want
to know who hired you to kidnap truman
[Music]
you just zenato it go oh
[Music]
venus for all
[Music]
[Music]
hmm
sounds like there's some emotional
baggage nearby i should try to get that
sword here
[Music]
everyone has emotional baggage that
needs to be sorted you can help out by
fanning this bag
hopefully it's the one that i've already
had the tag too every five you reunite
with around the rank
[Music]
i just want to play the first game and
me and my friends just talking about it
being like what would your world be like
you know inside your head because
the premise of this game if you don't
already know and find out but
you jump into other people's minds and
hence why you have all the emotional
baggage and the locked up memories and
stuff like that and everyone's mind
obviously it's very different the
location is very different the mechanics
are very different um the stories that
you learn
are very different because everyone is
different
so it's like what would you expect so
it's so interesting just to think about
it
[Music]
i will get this
[Music]
oh yes got it
[Music]
ugh
burning all the big ones just in case
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
who are you protecting
[Music]
i think i hear some emotional baggage
nearby
but where's the tag to it
hmm
[Music]
i need the purse tag here
[Music]
i think i hear something
yeah i know i know
where do we think
we think it might be behind one of these
[Music]
whatever
i don't know
[Music]
was that you screaming
on me
doesn't matter listen we all have our
doubts and regrets but it's too late to
turn back now
understand
what we have to do now
is finish the extraction
[Music]
lily i think lubato is starting to have
doubts duh they're right over there
[Applause]
luckily they're highly flammable
you take care of them while i find a way
out okay
[Music]
those things can really slow you down
yeah oh no i'm on fire
[Music]
this brain candy will restore some of
your mental energy hold down to gobble
oh
[Music]
that's right
[Music]
is a
psycho-reactive material used by
circonauts as currency saved up to buy
some useful stuff later okay wrap
doesn't this painting look familiar get
it away from me you scary little girl
think we should burn it oh yes you
haven't changed have you
come on just tell us who hired you not
my dad
this is really personal
you better believe it is well i'm sorry
if
uh
um
[Music]
and i was just trying to help him rest
while we waited for you to come and save
him
okay let's go then
oh no you don't i think i just did
mia
yes darling
nothing
did you forget everything i taught you
about levitation rasputin
no
your thoughts can lift you up if you
focus
better hurry before we hit the ground
there you go
now let's get out of here the bottle
needs our help yes wait help lobato
someone really did a number on that poor
thing i think he wants to tell us who
hired him and he's terrified let's find
him and help him
double jump
[Music]
just like the first game
two tags here
[Music]
there's no way we can get over there
[Music]
guys yeah
okay not that way not that
don't
way
darling
this way this way come on we can do this
first tag
[Music]
um
popping whenever i get there maybe i
have to jump here
i want to get that jeez
i want this
[Music]
um
[Music]
how do i get there then
[Music]
okay
is
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this
up
oh
[Music]
mia the mission is falling apart we've
lost control of lubato there's a little
chaos on every mission roz
a psychonaut must always remember how to
roll with it you remember how to gather
your thoughts and roll with them right
press alt t while on the ground to use
levitation
i also have just remembered her
thoughts because you go into her brain
uh in the first game and it is it gets
dark there's like a hidden a hidden bit
in her mind and i'm gonna spoil it for
you just in case you want to play the
first game but it's really dark
you don't expect it because she seems
like such a chill lovely lady right not
to say that she's not she is but
something really traumatic happened to
her
and it's pretty sad
what is this is this because i need to
be levitating
all right yes
what do you want me to do
i can't do that
oh god really how
did you go down there you want me to go
literally over
and around here because that seems
insane to me
i'll try this we'll see what happens
yeah insane i don't know why it's got
these balls like telling me that i
should be doing this today
definitely can't follow them
can i
oopsie
oopsie
oh my gosh
let's just go down here
this is not my kind of party
mia
where are you
sasha i can't reach mia i think she's
been demented
sasha
coach
really
oh no
i think i'm the last one still in here
maybe this is something that i get later
[Music]
oh
suitcase
it's really pretty i remember for some
reason i remember when
um
it was either when the game first got
announced or something like that
that people were saying basically just
dissing the graphics of the game because
it doesn't look realistic and stuff i'm
like
come on a game can look beautiful and be
stylized
and have its own unique
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
especially like unreal make it so
so much easier um
to make realistic
graphics especially with um what is it
quicksilver they have their partnership
with crypto bricksville is amazing
so
many wonderful textures to you
not to say that obviously anyone can do
it it's a realistic game if you have a
realistic game
just look great obviously it does but
i'm just like
you've got to appreciate your cohesive
unique
visual art style
it's hard to do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what was i supposed to do again
it's him
i've got to stop him
oh
[Music]
[Music]
um
i put the old
um
[Music]
i put the egg in the box and the box in
the basket and the basket in the ocean
no no
that's not it put the old wax in the
basket and the egg in the ocean you put
the egg in the basket and the old egg in
the box
and the box in the ocean
simple and if you tell anyone about me
anyone at all
you'll have to deal with her
no
please don't make me look at her again
no no i won't tell i won't kill anyone i
promise
oh please
wow
woman
angry screams
no
not her i won't count
[Music]
that bozo's brain was booby-trapped
yes whoever hired lobato to kidnap
truman knew he might be psychically
interrogated the whole thing looks
terrifying did anyone get a good look at
his boss
i saw him but i couldn't tell who he was
and i saw
something else
i saw the thing that terrified lobato
it was
a woman
dressed in black fur weird like she was
floating over the ruins of a city
and she was commanding serpents of
water
there was something familiar about her
rasputin i'm going to show you a picture
that's her yeah wait a second
i thought i recognized her true psychic
tales issue 43. she's on the cover
maligula
she's been dead for 20 years fort
crawler killed her himself a battle from
which he never truly recovered she was a
monster a ruthless power-hungry psychic
who drowned hundreds of her own
countrymen
nevertheless she still has a loyal
followers to this day
this file documents recent activity
believed to be the work of these modern
day delusionaries
what are they up to
well it's ridiculous really there's no
scientific basis to
[Music]
necromancy what they're trying to bring
her back to life
it's silly darling but if they believe
they can do it they might do some
dangerous things
mia have you considered the other
disturbing fact in all of
unstable character could never kidnap
the grand head of the psychonauts
without help
yes
you mean
there's a mole in the psychonauts
you think this is a mole you're dumber
than you look
[Music]
approaching the mother lube
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
agent forsyth why did you deny us intel
when we hailed the mother lode
what are you talking about agent nine we
were on a mission to rescue the grand
head of the psychonauts when we called
for assistance
i never heard any call who did you talk
to
is he all right oh that must be the
other mole i know for sure until we get
that squirrel tested for rabies
this
is our kidnapper
clearly he had help on the inside
impossible a mole in the psychonauts
we have reason to believe delusionists
are involved and they're trying to bring
back maligula what i know
isn't it great
psychonauts haven't had this kind of a
threat in years can someone help me with
my dad
he's still acting funny
truman
let's get him inside so he can lie down
what a fabulous beard
i'll see what i can find out in my
meditation chamber
i'm taking labato to my office for
further interrogation
i'm gonna talk to otto about our
military options
does that make anyone else a little
nervous
who are you
i'm razz
rasputin
i'm uh
your newest psychonaut
how's that
if ford crawler he gave me a badge
i've been kind of helping out
listen kid agent kruller is a hero
but he's not operating at a hundred
percent he can hand out all the merit
badges he wants but he doesn't have the
authority to commission psychonauts
but you can right
your hall is forsyth lesser head of the
psychonauts
true psychic tales 146 you and truman
fought the noodler together i prefer the
title second head if the other agents
vouch for you i might be able to get you
a spot
in the intern program
but don't be late for orientation i hear
the coordinator's a real brain buster
welcome to the mother lobe
[Music]
hello
hey is it okay if i go up into the main
headquarters now
i'm sorry little boy but there just
aren't any school tours today
what
i'm an intern
agent forsyth gave me this
really
let's check your head in the fingerprint
reader please
well i'll be doused
welcome to the intern program
let me get your orientation materials
what a nice picture this field manual
will act as your guide to the world of
psychonauts your progress is tracked
here along with information you gather
on your journey to becoming a junior
psychonaut when in doubt press
i think that's start or something on a
playstation controller to consult your
manual
your internship progress is tracked on
this page in term rank is key to
unlocking new psychic abilities increase
your rank by finding psi challenge cards
and markers in the real world or nuggets
of wisdom in mind wow
that picture really captures my
startled side
[Music]
unique items what's this
a psi portal this trusted parasite
portal is my pocket-sized door it's a
mental world cool
this section of your manual tracks the
progress of any psi powers you are
authorized to use while in the intern
program as your rank increases you will
earn intern credit which you can spend
here for psi power upgrades use of
unauthorized powers is strictly oh looks
like i can choose where to focus my
energy and upgrade my powers
very interesting
okay i've got no credits available but
we can update these which is cool
as a psychonaut it's
it's important to always be aware of
your surroundings this section of the
manual tracks your exploration okay
gotta keep track of all the places i've
been here
oh i got 76 out of 80 figments that must
have been the slide because i know i
missed i missed a few on the slides
oh cool someone said here
um
where's that
sunset watcher in the first game if you
put cheat code in the old man we'll say
you cheated that's really funny
my mission draw down yeah okay so
maps are always useful
this is a weird map it's just pictures
uh we can go to
limited access including the cafe
bowling alley and hair salon
we can go to the noodle bowl
levitation lounge the bathroom
mission log tracks any official
psychonauts missions you undertake as
part of the intern program consult this
section for active missions
i'll keep my to-do list here report to
the classroom horace forsythe wants me
to report to the intern coordinator in
the classroom the map i got reception to
refine it
uh classroom classroom classroom
m
where am i right now
oh my gosh
a
okay there i am
and so it says uh top left
uh where's the bathrooms for some reason
i just want to go to the bathrooms
okay oh that's left oh it's by the
needle bar the noodle bowl
the noodle bell
what about the hair salon
oh
oh wait is that
it's oh everything i wanted
scanning for fingerprint
access granted
[Music]
wow
i can't believe i'm really here
psychonauts headquarters
sorry new
[Music]
the future of psycho technology in my
lab right now this automatic has all the
psychic supplies and enhancements you
need
have a look around
idea let's make a side challenge marker
and get you ranked up
[Music]
oh
[Music]
pins
[Music]
take one of these
[Music]
excellent choice
[Music]
[Music]
so much cool stuff in there i'll come
back later for the rest of it
give me up here
we've got psychos cypops and the ever
popular dream fluffs here at the
automatic what's up chief
i love when you just get to parts like
this and games and you just like walk
around talking to people and just seeing
the new area
hello
wow
here they are
the psychic six
the group of paranormal experts ford
kruller gathered together to form the
psychonauts
i read all about them in true psychic
tales number one
tragically
none of them were the same after
fighting maligula
in the deluge of
grulovia less tragically but still
upsetting
my mom used that issue of true psychic
tales to line the floor of the world's
smallest horse trailer
did you see the way agent forsyth storm
through here she doesn't find a way to
let off some steam soon she's going to
crack she needs a vacation hey don't we
all
ford crawler
the greatest psychonaut of all time and
a close personal friend of mine i might
add a compton
master of solepathy if he's anything
like his grandson dogan he can be a
little dangerous if he gets overwhelmed
which is often
ottoman talis was ford's first recruit
use cytadium to engineer psycho-reactive
and psycho-enhancing devices
there's bob zenato pioneer in human
plant telepathy and he's lily's great
uncle
helmut ober explored a synthesis of
psychic powers of the arts
sadly
he was lost in the battle of molovia
that's cassiopeia best-selling author of
mind sword expert in extreme
multitasking and mental
compartmentalization
[Music]
do you know where intern orientation is
second floor past the classroom
thanks
if you passed the restrooms you went the
wrong way
but are we recruiting from kindergartens
now
excuse me
please let me ageist
no running hello hey sonny
i absolutely thought i just felt
something on my head
no running
i found a massive spider in my flats the
other day so i've been a bit on the edge
okay
no running
[Music]
another caviar team in the air vent
rich people are weird
[Music]
please report to my office immediately
for assignment
i wonder what those goggles are for
greetings agent hi
hi
doesn't that helmet get in the way of
your agent hello
stranger
consider buying a suit kid
hey i need that
[Music]
i wish you could just find money and
plants in real life
[Music]
i get a vacation
[Music]
[Music]
where's the toilet
immediately
before i forget
have you guys tried the new smooth ultra
beige low pop stock no what's so special
about that it's double-sided wow
what will they think of next hey kid
hi hey little agent
order anything nah
i'm holding out for the bacon you are a
honey pepper fool toilet
oh what
so is this bacon really worth it well
it's made from honey pepper balls which
are really rare gosh
you know so much about bacon that's so
sexy hi huh
[Music]
so what's good today why do i bother
making signs
[Music]
wow
you agents share recipes you're just
like us uh yeah right recipes
[Music]
hey hey uh-huh
[Music]
okay okay let's stop stalling and go to
the class
wait then the paper i've been using is
illegal no it's a four
i have this weird urge to go shopping
[Music]
[Music]
hey you there i'm sure you're a powerful
psychic but wouldn't you like to be a
little uh
extra
[Music]
well if it isn't my favorite customer
[Music]
i'm
[Music]
but it says i can buy it
[Music]
i think that might be good to have
hold some extra pops
[Music]
[Music]
i like all this all the pouches are good
physically enhances enhancement
accessory harnesses and folding
technology loads more
it's like me
which one do i want i want them all
[Music]
don't be a stranger
[Music]
hey look out oh sorry i didn't whoa wow
that's mean
did he hurt you baby i'm not a baby yeah
you are
question is who's this new kid oh
they'll be my name is razz and i'm
the new intern
that's ridiculous i didn't ask for a new
intern
intern program's fool sorry kid he is
clumsy
he'd probably get us all killed and he's
mean
[Music]
well kid we give it a fair shot and it
looks like it just didn't work out
better luck next year guys
quit picking on the new kid
we were all new once in case you forgot
i think he'll fit in just fine
in fact i think he'll look cute in our
uniform
let's take him to the closet
we get a uniform
hey are you okay in there rusty
what's going on
it's razz
i was just wondering if there's an
intern uniform how come you guys aren't
wearing it
oh
well
we're level two
now just hand out your clothes and we'll
get you that uniform
can't you hand me the uniform first
no silly
we need to take your clothes and measure
them so we can get you a uniform that
fits unless you want us to come in there
and measure you
no no
here you go
just hurry up okay
it's cold in here and i'm practically
naked
uh oh
guys
oh come on
this is embarrassing in so many ways
oh
oh dude
i just read that i'm a bit quiet
compared to the game so i'm just gonna
turn the game down a bit
let me know
if that's any better
hopefully that's a bit better
[Music]
high five
i'll take that card
yes yes i will
[Music]
there's a narrow slop but i don't think
i can fit through it
oh
[Music]
[Music]
i don't have a key
agent
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
there it is
i'll bet this key goes to that supply
chest i found
[Music]
i don't know the code
rats
oh sorry harold you're absolutely right
i should think about how i'm using that
word
what is it harold do you know the code
is the code in there harold
i'm too big to go in there
if only i could see what you see in
there
hey
that reminds me
clairvoyance lets you see through the
eyes of other people or animals using it
on anyone displaying i aura can reveal
hidden information about the world use
their voice
i can't even remember all my powers now
oh it's the hand
gotcha okay
okay
let's use it instead of fire for the
time being maybe or hand
hand because i've been using fire quite
a lot
[Music]
i think i winged it
[Music]
time to see the world as you see it
harold
[Music]
you see so much
[Music]
oh
[Music]
wrong way
uh oh no
[Music]
we got him right where we want him yet
we still can't extract the information
we need
have you tried the corpus callocerator
sasha you have to let me do more you
know it's because of me that at all i
mean if i hadn't
until i find you some new clothes
sorry if the fit is a little off they're
the smallest clothes i had now uh tell
us again how you ended up outside in
your underwear oh you know i was sort of
going undercover just like you did agent
mentalis in true psychic tales number 62
when you used your defributlobber to
hypnotize 16 trans troopers at once oh
please that old yarn they embellished so
many details in that version but in fact
it was 17 troopers
well love to chat but i gotta make like
a brain and bounce
if you're ever looking for just the
right tool for the job
the best psychonauts require a little
assistance now and then
now if you'll excuse me rasputin i need
to get back to the matter at hand
oh no
i didn't bend the spoons mommy
i love going through the car wash
oh and don't worry about the other
interns rescue initiation rituals are a
common method for a specialized social
group to integrate foreign elements
while preserving the social exclusivity
i'm so glad i've never had to do any
initiative
if you would just cooperate with our
investigation
i'd like to but i can't i know you're
scared but if you could just tell me who
no no
[Music]
hey hmm
yes but stand back it's due for a
thorough day lousy if i can ever
convince hollis to pay for it
hey this is just like the brain tumbler
you had it yes but stand back if i can
ever convince hollis to pay for it
hey what's this thing stay away from
that please everything is tuned to my
precise head size and shape
right ahead like yours would damage the
machine irreparable he's basically just
asking me to leave him the hell of all
hey is this normal sasha all the lights
flashing on your computer like this oh
yes i like to leave it on demo mode for
the ambiance
okay sasha i'll leave you alone now
oh that's the wall
yeah
need any help sasha yes from him me
help me find the answers i need oh so
this is all my fault yes
have any suspicions no that's the
frustrating thing how could anyone in
the psychonauts do this and how could
they keep it a secret
so about
maligula she's dead rasputin ford
crawler made sure of that nothing for
you to worry about of his imagination at
the moment
maybe he just hatched the scheme on his
own he has no motivation oh hello dad
someone hired him and given his access
to truman someone on the inside
happy birthday eve jones
at least we made it out of the rhombus
of ruin you performed well in the field
rasputin i'll make sure agent forsythe
finds out all about it in my report
just as soon as i'm done here
why do you think he won't cooperate i
seem to have such a big change of heart
back in the rhombus someone has
conditioned him hypnotically to be
unable to tell us even if he wanted to
but who
i'll let you get back to the
interrogation
sorry i can't help you've done a lot
rasputin thank you see even that going
through his head it's i kind of like how
it's not
because he i guess he was the villain of
the first game but obviously he found
that he wasn't actually the villain
there's someone else
behind this and i like that because it's
things aren't just
oh
it's a moon or something things aren't
just black and white
i look like a moon uh
and it's from going into his head you're
learning
yeah about manipulation
he's being manipulated
he's not just a bad person
hey kid
oh cute
i look adorable there's a card behind me
whoa
[Music]
i
can't leave this card lying around
[Music]
bye
[Music]
oh this is the meditation room
oh fine
yep
is this a bad time here i always have
time for my kitten gino
are you worried about maligula
well she died in the bottle of grulovia
but sometimes the idea of someone is
more dangerous than the person
themselves
her followers are what scare me
when someone devotes their life to a
memory they're capable of anything
are you meditating in a way
i'm reaching out to detect ripples in
the psychic network around the world
ripples
a name like maligula carries heavy
emotional baggage for many people it's
like a large stone dropped in a pond
ripples spread out bounce off each other
if you know how to read the patterns
they can lead you to the source
what are you doing that for
i'm trying to find the illusionist
activity around the world and report it
to asian foresight down in the nerve
center
can i ask you about the psychic six
of course rasputin
are any of them still around
oh yes besides ford you know there's
ottoman tales out in his workshop still
tinkering with his gadgets
sasha is his number one customer dogman
bull's
compton is here as well but he
he keeps to himself the other survivors
have gone their own ways unfortunately
what happened to
helmet full bear
oh that poor soul was lost in the battle
of grulovia
i wish i could have met him he seemed to
have such a love of life and color
did you ever meet cassiopeia
no but i read her book mindswarm
very inspiring i'm actually using some
of her multitasking techniques right now
talking to you while i work
did you ever work with lily's great
uncle bob zanato
oh yes poor bob he lost so much in the
battle it really took a toll on him i
know it was very difficult for truman to
let him go but it was getting dangerous
oh what that poor family has endured
well enough about those guys
yes let's talk about us
she looks like an actual butterfly
hey kai thanks for coming i'm playing um
psychonauts 2. it came out yesterday
it's the sequel to psychonauts which
came out when i was like a kid so very
exciting explores
a lot of deep topics
uh mental health things as well
but in in a nice informative and
creative and imaginative way so it's a
very nice game
are you worried about truman to be
honest i've never seen him like this
before
but he's very tough and he has his
fearless daughter in there now taking
care of him
have you talked to sasha lately
sasha and i are always talking
oh he says hello
well i'll stop bothering you now never a
bother darling ciao
she's so nice
okay
nothing more in this room oh no there's
a key
oh cool supply chest
keep an eye out
probably should be set prior to her
stuff that's really mean okay let's go
oh there is money here though
hello
[Music]
that was a dirty trick you pulled i want
my clothes back
you know you're right
i'm sorry
and i'm going to make it up to you
i'm going to let you finish my asset
recovery mission
why do i feel like i'm going to end up
naked in a closet again
my intern assignment is to track down
this list of missing psychonaut assets
mission critical assets
so
like a scavenger hunt if you think like
a child you will do a child's work
finish this mission
and we'll know you're ready for your
clothes back
i don't think these are the type of
friends you want really your internship
will sometimes present extra credit
opportunities you can check
your extra credit for your clothes
you can track these uh options this
looks like a good place to track my side
missions
report to
office
that's two
oh is that my side mission
exit
mila sasha one three four what's two
don't really know
every mind is unique and if you want to
customize your psi powers to suit your
personal style you'll want to get some
pins
i do i do have bins i need more pins
i need all pins
oh now i've got a red ball
i have credits so i could buy things
uh hmm what should i buy
i think like the levitation could be
good your levitation ball will damage
enemies if you slam into them at high
speeds
not bad
um
[Music]
have you already got that one
press x while dodging to execute joshua
fling objects
hold to charge your blast with bigger
explosion reveal hidden objects stay
visible longer
oh that would be good as well though
okay i'm gonna have this one i know it's
only for emergencies
but i really feel like trying it's like
i got a little more spring in my
levitation
noise noise
so much more fun just to hit everything
than it is to interact with things
can i do this did that work no not even
a grand slam
knock it off
hey sam
aren't you not supposed to tap the glass
no it's the opposite you're supposed to
tap on the glass to keep their heart
rates up
in this predator-free environment their
heart rates get dangerously slow
plus they love it i mean look at him
jump
i don't think they love it
i think you're mean
leave a like with it
you can knock them
so what do we interns usually
do depends on who your mentor is
mentor
oh jeez raz don't you have a mentor yet
get on up to hollis office and get one
right now
go or i'll toss you up there like a dang
goat
okay okay okay
yep
oh no okay
i had to buy some things
hey hey fish you're pretty
i'm really late to intern orientation
now i better get to the class right away
that person's aura is telling me their
perspective on the world is especially
what's seen
with clairvoyance
thank you
[Laughter]
so stupid i love it
oh my god
[Music]
the music clue enough for this i'll tell
you that twice
who else loves bacon this much
yep that was uh quite something
very special
if there are layoffs maybe i'll get a so
if i bring you back all these scavenger
hunt items mission critics give me my
old yes definitely
if i can find them i will 100 give them
back
these new pins the very latest
new things
wow
no no no no no no
that'll get you out of a sticky
situation
[Music]
oh
[Music]
because i'm the one who has to clean up
all the wheel marks everything okay here
should be because skateboarding is not a
psychic crime and i'm not arresting you
i'm just saying take it outside
fine
happy i could help
you guys still arguing
nah frank's just telling me where all
the good outdoor skate spots are so you
were saying something about a
questionable area yeah hopefully the
funicular is running
oh sick
teach me things
star
circle square triangle
wow
would it be weird if i asked for the
sasha it doesn't look open yet though
okay okay let's actually do
it's just not safe to use clairvoyance
without my special clairvoyance
enhancing pins
what about sasha and mia i keep getting
so distracted by everything
[Music]
experts agree it's just not safe to use
clairvoyance
without my special clairvoyance
enhancing pins
scanning for fingerprints
experts agree it's just not safe to use
clairvoyance
without my special clairvoyance
enhancing pins
[Music]
it's going to be back feeling faster
because they
took my clothes and locked me out
hey hi hey cutie
experts agree it's just not safe to use
clairvoyance
without my special clairvoyance
enhancing pins
i love these things
nice
oh
with that sci card i can make a side
challenge marker back at the automatic
[Music]
did someone say something about pirate
radio no yes morris is doing it and it's
totally against the roles and he's gonna
get kicked out of the psychonauts lizzy
you're fired dream on
can i be a pirate radio dj what's your
area of musical expertise well i grew up
in the circus so most of what i know is
calliope music i see looks like you
don't need me anymore morris listen i'll
get back to you kid
once i get my pirate radio station going
i'm gonna have a few not many dj jobs
over
[Music]
get a hold of yourself oleander
fighting malignant without my battle
fight
[Music]
hey i'm with you
letting him build a battle anything is
probably a bad idea
[Music]
oh right new intern
thought i told you not to be late
doesn't matter you need a mentor
let me see who's left
am i helping mia or sasha on a mission
no
you're in the mail room
your mentor is nick john smith
mail room
nick john smith
i've never heard of an agent john smith
nick's not an agent he's not even
psychic he's just good at sorting mail
you'll love nick everybody does
but
the mail room
ford crawler himself worked in that mail
room you could learn a lot there for one
thing how to be on time i mean she has a
point okay
i've given you fingerprint access to the
mailroom now school
i've got a base to run and a budget to
balance
[Music]
where do i find my mentor again no why
can't you remember this
because i'm five
[Music]
bye
oh
hey
uh how's your dad
terrible i gotta go get him some therapy
plants
how'd you get that hatch open
oh it's got a fingerprint combination i
can teach it to you come here
it's more than just a number you kind of
have to feel it
do you feel it
yes good
tell anybody you got it for me and
you're dead
bye
[Music]
like ah
she touched me
[Music]
thank you for following sammy the
destroyer what a name thanks for
following
now you can access also bray alto's
brain only network for quick travel
around the mother lode
[Music]
okay good to know good to make it
tonight
[Music]
i can't go into
can i i thought interns won't allow them
here
[Music]
is this not where they locked me
there's a narrow slop but i don't think
i can fit through it
harold what have you found out about the
mall
nothing
[Music]
check these new pins the very latest
[Music]
let's combine that psycho with your card
so you can rank up
[Music]
psychic
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
okay
now
should i do my side mission or carry on
with the main
see if i think my side vision i reckon
that's a mission to like explore
everywhere so
and that's basically what i'm doing
nowadays
available in my shop for testing i mean
for purchase they're totally safe
not available to internships
rub that in now
you kids think you're better than us
just because
[Music]
wow
a bully psychic doesn't look open though
[Music]
what's this
secret auto code
okay i got three points
hold to compress your level and release
the bounce high in the air maybe that's
how i get up there
well i hope so because
agent 33 please report to agent
forsyth's office
oh yeah i was going to
how do i find all these things
they just spotted around
i guess
i guess i'll just be in different rooms
for thinker
wow
this
is the nerve center
where they track psychic activity and
operations around the world i can't
believe they let me in here mother can i
[Music]
i love the soundtrack
[Music]
why are they looking at a goat or a
sheep
they'll let anyone be an agent these
days
[Music]
other status reports
[Music]
that's affirmative
scanning for fingerprint
access granted
where are we going
exactly it really looks like we
shouldn't be allowed in
[Music]
here in this water oh no no no no in
that water
[Music]
it's just not safe to use clairvoyance
without my special clairvoyance
enhancing
wow
the office of truman zanato
grand head of the psychonauts
poor lily
[Music]
what just happened to that plant
[Music]
just muted itself over towards us
oops okay maybe i should stop i'm sorry
lily
can i get you anything you can find out
who did this to him so i can kill them
okay
did your dad have any enemies
no well lots actually if you count all
the international criminals he's busted
but they're all in jail
is truman doing better
no he's doing worse on the way home he
was talking at least but now he's not
even doing that
but i brought him some of my most
psycho-sensitive plants they should help
me figure out what's going on
[Music]
oh
[Music]
okay i think i'm ready to talk about
that time we
met
razz that was like a few days ago
right well i'm uh
glad it happened
me too razz chickening out
that's cute though
do you want to be alone
you can stay
but i'm afraid i'm not very good company
right now
you ever have a fight with anybody only
uncle bob but you know
family stuff
what did he fight about with uncle bob
well
my great uncle bob zenato was a founding
member of the psychonauts you know a
master of psychoerbology but after the
big fight with maligula he
he sort of fell apart
he became a danger to himself and other
agents
my dad had to fire him her little time
was like
fired by your little nephew but uncle
bob would never hurt dad ah
okay
i'm going to work on the small thing if
you find out you got to tell me before
you tell anyone else if you want real
justice to be served
oh
okay
[Music]
oh what's this picture of
wait
no that's
one of them with like a big burger
i think it's a big burger
[Music]
scanning for thinker print
access denies no
fine
okay smell you later
[Music]
we can't find any of these things that
she wants me to find
nothing in his office am i gonna have to
smash up everything because i feel
really bad doing that
so
[Music]
oopsies
skeleton thing
[Music]
okay let's go to the mail room
have not yet contacted them mr john
smith i'm doing upstairs hello
but i will soon new intern here
titania must be stronger than the stuff
in camp these animals are powerful
[Music]
oh no he's scanning me because i
accidentally shot him
i'm sorry i'm sorry
where is nick i can't remember the last
time i saw him
[Music]
he's usually so organized
what a mess
who's talking
hmm there's a narrow slot but i don't
think i can fit
how could nick let it get like this
everything okay in here
who are you i'm uh nick john smith's new
intern oh so you're the one not sorting
all this mail wait better get all this
mail sorted quick you're making nick
look bad
uh
i have to change this now
where do i sort it
it's got a brain on it
ah
oh
this package is addressed to truman
zanato
hey
this might be important i'd better bring
it to truman technically
this is official psychonauts business
no
okay
okay
nothing
yes not this way
hmm
there's a narrow slop i don't think i
can
can i get up here
oh
yes
get up there
get up
easy does it tiny tiny steps
four inter credits for me
got a side card
oh
i'm sure we'll come back
we'll figure it out
oh yeah what am i doing
that did some damage
come on rasputin precious cargo
yeah but this place is a mess
wait i just had to make shine whoops oh
dear
cannot drop something instead of
chucking it oh
oh
that's so bad about that i'm sorry i
didn't mean to make you can't leave this
card lying around
hey you guys gotta check this out the
new kid killed nick
he's alive but he's
brainless
that's a bit scary
what kind of sick monster would steal
nick's brain
i mean nick
maybe he saw something he shouldn't have
but why keep his body alive
and why mail it to the grand head of the
psychonauts
it could be a warning
hey guys
does the
lady loctopus casino mean anything to
you
isn't that where we sent agent 33
to investigate suspected delusionist
activity agent 33 is two days late with
her status update
i'll get the jet i'll pack the gold case
i'll stay here and protect the children
what
aren't we all going on the mission we
could use you in tactical command agent
forsythe
and maybe the interns would benefit from
it's not safe not while we have a double
agent among us
i'll take your place
i've heard the buffet there is
shockingly reasonable
well if you reconsider meet us on the
jetpad within the hour
all of you to the interns bay now
i've got some training exercises planned
today that are both informative and safe
last one there has to delaus the brain
tumbler
tv
oh dude
i'll bet those guys took nick's body
back to the mail
i should go check and see if he's okay
he is my mentor after all okay let's go
back to the mailroom
um i think i saw tom
yeah hey tom i'm playing this on game
pass
it's really good so far
i'm pretty enjoying it granted
a lot of like exploring it and world
building um but
especially if you play the first game
definitely
check it out
so where is his body
maybe they've opened that room
hello mentor
[Music]
is
[Music]
this is a robot
insufficient postage
postage hey what's behind here
no i didn't
it's a flying post
[Music]
how do we get into that room
[Music]
hey howie
[Music]
got some new gadgets available in my
shop for testing i mean for purchase you
think these nights
are available
huge deal
how can you think about bowling in a
time like this we all deal with stress
in our
yeah like how you kids like teddy bears
and blankets
i still like teddy bears and blankets
wow
[Music]
a psychic bowl doesn't look open though
can
yeah and that makes you suspect number
one
i mean
sure
the other interns think so but i don't
think everyone
intern
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
please report
right away
hell is think
how am i supposed to know these things
okay fine
ah
wait
just thinking about nick
you know oh that's right
he mailed that letter for you that one
time didn't he
yeah
means so much to me
oh this is the bacon man the man that
only sees bacon
[Music]
and he sees this is like a smelly little
runt
what does she see then
oh she's in love with bacon man
oh yeah we met her we met these two at
the noodle bar and she was saying oh he
knows so much about bacon ah
she's um
she's got unique taste wait she sees me
as a cigarette machine
that's weird
i love this mechanic i think it's so
cool
see how other people see you
see
hello
[Music]
you want a cigarette hello
cigarette hello
so stupid
[Music]
the very latest
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
no refunds
[Music]
you're finally here let me know when
you're prepared to learn something
do i just lie in bed
yes please
this is a class i am here for don't wait
too long you'll miss class
[Music]
if i may speak you may not class is in
session
[Music]
can i ask please hold all questions till
the end of the lesson
agent forsyth
that mission is being handled by
experienced psychonauts
do not bring it up again
when does class start as soon as you get
to my classroom
[Music]
this isn't your classroom no
this is always good so are you ready kid
yeah yeah
and what are you ready for
safety
oh
you think the human mind is safe
that's cute
[Music]
[Applause]
and that is how you perform the advanced
psychic ability known as mental
connection
cool
and i thought i just had to be a ball
and just bounce around but no
[Music]
oh sorry could you repeat that
sorry kid i warned you not to be late
i'm off to attend to some fiduciary
concerns
norma take over for me won't you you can
practice with some of those loose ideas
but agent forsyth is it safe to leave
all these thoughts out like this if
you're not here norma please
it takes more than a few rambunctious
children to affect the mind of a trained
psychonaut
[Music]
oh
what are you doing
try not to fall asleep in my class
all right repscallion
okay
now how do i explain mental connection
extremely simply let me guess we focus
on an idea in someone's mind until we
form a tangible connection with it
oh
i didn't realize you're a mental
connection expert
by all means
give us a demo
professor i'm sure he can do it
let's see what you got little guy
whereas just do it so my sister shuts up
mental connection grapple between
thoughts to make connections okay
[Music]
what the heck did you just do
i said connect with the idea
not jump inside it like a hamster ball
sorry
old habit from the circus i guess
[Music]
not only is cilantro delicious it's
affordable and easy to grow in a window
box herb garden
what the heck is that
what
you left a slime trail
it's like he connected the two thoughts
together
oh
now you're in trouble
hey what's the big idea
looks like
disgust
well i'm sure it's not the first time
rasputin has created that thought in
someone's mind
okay
i know cilantro reduces the risk of
digestive distress
but it tastes like soap
and honestly i'd rather have the gas
hey rez
if you can change forsythe's opinion of
cilantro
maybe you could change her mind about
the casino mission
[Music]
i don't know what that doesn't
manipulate you yeah i mean she worries
about us kids too much it's taking years
off of her life expectancy
hmm
if you could get her not to be so
worried all the time we could all go on
a real psychonauts mission
well i don't suppose it would hurt to
take a look around up there
just see if there's any you know
problems
let's get all of this
straight to the top bras of course if
you're scared
don't do it
you'll probably get kicked out of the
psychopaths for trying but what the heck
nuggets of wisdom oh
funny one will impart enough
concentrated wisdom to get in connect
those thoughts young man try not to kill
her brain razz
remember
it's for the good of the mission
straight to the top
of course if you're scared
don't do it i mean
you'll probably get kicked out of the
psychonauts for trying but what the heck
connect those thoughts young man try not
to kill her brain razz
remember
it's for the good of the mission oh
here's the steamer trunk tag
okay is that all of them down here
of course if you're scared
don't do it i mean not only is cilantro
delicious it's affordable and easy to
grow
reduces the risk of digestive distress
but it tastes like soap
and honestly i'd rather have the gas
the kids
[Music]
these barriers keep parts of our brains
off limits see if one of your other psi
powers can break through them maybe the
pew pew pew or gun
a pp
yes
oh wait
this was a terrible idea
[Music]
you got mini
rob when were you left don't know what
they're in for
[Music]
if i let them go to that casino
that's it
they'd be dead
i'm not letting another agent get hurt
on my watch
i need to keep them safe
i don't want her to know i'm here
but without funding how can i yeah this
was a bad idea i'm going back
how can i find this mole
who would steal
our lady of restraint neurological
hospital i think hollis said she was an
intern here once
i always had my best ideas here
let's just hope i don't run into dr putz
maybe trying to change her mind is a bad
idea
[Music]
[Applause]
bad idea can blow up in your face
i'll check that out that's so sweet if
you didn't have to do but like thank you
so much i will check it out
how how do i kill i didn't read this
thing
i didn't read it okay i'm guessing
all
[Music]
food
[Music]
yes
no room in here for any bad ideas but my
own
speaking of i gotta catch up to hollis
and try to change your mind about the
mission she could help her then if we're
getting rid of herbert
[Music]
uh let's hit some stuff and
try and gain some health here we go
i've got enough credit to upgrade one of
my scythes
[Music]
i think i hear some emotional bag this
hat box needs a half box tag
[Music]
boom
[Music]
happy baggage
find more tags
[Music]
oh there's some chickens over there
oh pigeons would they want to be
chickens why would they be up there
[Music]
he does it
i think i hear something
[Music]
oh my god look at the size of that kid's
head get him to radiology stat
he looks like
wait is that me
look it's me
you saved another life dr potts oh
please i was just doing my job
i heard the technique you used was
developed by your intern hollis forsythe
oh uh my intern
yes yes well we did collaborate on that
a little
a little
the patient will make a full recovery dr
potts all thanks to you
and your brilliant intern hollis
forsythe why uh yes when she has been a
helpful assistant
give him a credit
uh i like the look of these this brain
has made amazing progress another life
saved by the forsyth method the the pops
method thoughts it was my invention that
in turn merely transcribed my dictation
oh huh
apologies dr potts in fact i was
thinking of getting
yeah we all know people like that oh
waiting on people like that
is
[Music]
this little guy's lost his mind half of
it anyway if you can reunite him with
the other half you gain a whole brain of
mental energy
i've got half a mind to look for the
other half
something tells me it's not too far away
good luck collecting your debts after
i'm dead losers
there's the other half
do i get like another one to keep
forever i do okay awesome i thought it
might just be an extra
brain of health uh
as in
regaining what i might have lost but no
i'm getting a hologram
to go with my
current brains
hmm
at our current burn rate
that's no good
maybe if i move some thumbs around
i could postpone paying those bills
dr potts is the pits
working your ass off
creating the foresight method
giving it to her boss him making it the
potts method
journal of neuroscience the pops method
changing mind to mental connection
did she change his mind
another grand is off the table for sure
bet the gastronauts don't have to pinch
pennies like this
where am i gonna put the money for that
what if i eliminate some meals
i could cut my own paycheck for a
while i went to school for medicine how
did i end up stressing about money
management all day
well
i just need to put those thoughts aside
and focus on the children their safety
is the most important thing
and it's not just because a lawsuit
would bankrupt us right now
that casino mission would be good
experience for them
but it's too risky
what if i let them go when the worst
happens
we need to focus
only one unfathomable fear at a time
forsyth
if hollis associated risk was something
more positive than death it would open
her up to so many more missions
i mean
life experiences
yeah but you're also manipulating her
thoughts i don't like this i don't want
to do it
i feel bad
i guess she's not gonna notice us
because she's kind of in her own little
bubble right now
[Music]
i think i've collected every figment in
this mind oh hell yeah
money
death
mushrooms
[Music]
i always wash my hands after handling
cash you don't know where those bills
have been
[Music]
uh okay so we want death
to be with the light but what about foxy
sandals
[Music]
it's just that socks are so
it you shouldn't have them exposed when
you're on the street
my husband starts wearing socks with
sandals
if hollis wants to solve her money
problems she's gonna need to accept some
risk
i definitely could not handle that
stressful casino mission right now
stores undertake risks
but what use is it hmm
that's not the change i was going for
maybe delight and stress
who am i kidding if i wasn't worried
about something i wouldn't be me it just
means i care
[Music]
mushrooms
[Music]
stress and uh
money
i just remembered how dire the
psychonauts finances are interesting
but that's not going to help us go on
that casino
if the psychonauts don't get some more
funding soon i'm
well i'm going to die that's all there
is to it
just got the strangest urge
to go outside and kill some ants
must be from hanging out with these kids
at least it's only killing us maybe i
shouldn't have done that a little bit
weird
what do i do
maybe i'll make her love her
whenever i see socks with sandals it
reminds me of my favorite german college
professor
don't people who wear socks with sandals
worry about rattlesnake bites
[Music]
what are we going to do what am i going
to do
i don't know what to do should i put
children cilantro with
before it's fun to take risks
but what use is it i think the only way
to get hollis to take us on a mission to
a casino
is to get her to associate risks
thanks for helping
literally tell me exactly what to do uh
money is around the side though so how
am i gonna get there
can i just jump off
oh
[Music]
i think i think i just figured out how
to solve all our money problems
[Music]
and she's gonna be killing a bunch of us
[Music]
[Applause]
huh
hey teach
what gives i was in the middle of a
sweet hook up there guess what kids you
all did so well on your lesson how about
we give your new power a test drive out
in the field
you mean we're going on the mission
for real isn't that dangerous
you know what they say sam nothing
ventured nothing brained i don't think
that's what let's roll
heck yes
cool right sweet um
[Music]
i'm so glad you changed your mind about
the mission agent forsyth i was nervous
about bringing the children but if you
feel that it's safe then it must be it's
crucial we find out what these
delusionists are up to at the casino
with you handling tactical command i'd
say our probability of mission success
has risen 35 percent
i'll take those odds now how long do we
reach the ladies octopus
we are almost there
agent forsythe
how are you feeling
lucky
well we're here
using a false identity we have secured a
high roller suite to use of our base of
operations
now children you are not to leave the
suite like most casinos the lady
lactopus has a strict no psychics
be policy for this chance to observe
agent forsyth in action
this is shoehorn we are nearing cool
a new new environment already
[Music]
i'll approach the reception desk and
distract the clerks after they're
distracted i'll drop into the office and
find the room number that belongs to
this key just make sure to disable the
main van because my position is close
no need to explain agents you do your
job and i'll do mine let's keep radio
silent so i can
understood dustpan out
roger
concentrate
rasputin
don't sneak up on me like that
listen
do me a favor and run up to the jet will
you
i need my dowsing goggles i left them on
my seat i think
you wanted to be on a mission now here's
your first objective fetch my dowsing
goggles
okay but hurry our window of opportunity
is closing
all right i'll be right back
hey
maybe we should keep out of agent
forsyth's uh operations
theater
something is really not right with
hollis what did you do to her
what me nothing i just
made her love gambling
she's fine she just needs a little space
i cannot take my eyes off this train
wreck you are going to be in so much
trouble
what you doing morris i'll tell you what
i'm not doing
i'm not watching the pre-semi-final
practice vote to find out who's maybe
not going on to the next round of pop
gladiators
i can't believe it's half past
eleven ah
when did it get so late what the hell
i'm gonna have to stop streaming
[Music]
[Music]
hello
everything's good on the mission so far
you mean except for our mission
commander having a total breakdown it's
not a breakdown she's just strategizing
uh-huh
[Music]
potty stream to have a leg what are you
doing in there sam when agent forsyth
finally blows this will be the only safe
place
[Music]
what are you doing in there sam when
agent fourside finally blows this will
be the only safe place
[Music]
okay i'll just get her her goggles
come on
turn on
[Music]
i don't see any dousing goggles anywhere
i mean to be fair i have no idea what
they look like
i've actually never even heard of
dowsing
oh no
agent forsythe where are you going
[Music]
agent forsyth is missing but don't worry
i'll find her hurry rasputin we're in
big trouble here yes please find agent
forsythe right away i don't know how
long i can
hold on
i'm on it
[Music]
well then
i want a bird i can't go into the hotel
they have anti-psychic detectors
hollis must have some way to hide it
[Music]
next time
so has it just automatically saved
because i cannot save
it must have done
but yeah thank you so much for spending
a lot of time with me
it is much later than i realized but
that means that i was having
a really good time
i
i'm actually just really enjoying just
exploring every nook and cranny of this
and also remembering what happened in
the first game getting to know new
people talking to the old people
um i love i love the premise of
psychonauts i think it's so unique and
they have made this game look beautiful
as well so
i'm really excited to play more and i
will be playing more whether that's on
stream or not so if you do want me to
play more on stream give this video a
like if not we have more games
to play many many many more games
so no big deal but i will definitely be
playing more of this game because i very
much enjoy it i
i think it's definitely a game you can
kind of get lost in and just spend a lot
of time looking at the tiny details so i
understand that might not be the most
fun to watch but for me it's really fun
to play